crazy do you know what I'm not even
gonna restart the recording
that's the name review everyone creeper
oh man creeper I sucks creeper oh man
insecurity anxiety creeper oh man this
is of course the beautiful lyrics from
the song that everyone's heard what is
the Sun let me find it wait there's a
rap genius of CaptainSparklez revenge
featuring trihard ninja produced by docx
creeper oh man creepers are hostile mob
in Minecraft possibly the most iconic
mob in Minecraft phew oh man have you
guys ever played a discord game where
someone has you have to say creeper oh
man
the whole lyrics without in this is
really lyrics that makes me go peepee
poo-poo in my pants I love it so much
what if like in the comments section on
this video people just go creeper oh man
creeper oh man you know this is not
gonna be funny line it's already kind of
like all memes Felix oh okay sorry for
pointing out obvious observations this
creeper meme gets a creeper oh man next
meme all right guys love him or hate him
missing this was across men love em or
hate em love em or hate em he's spitting
facts and you gotta acknowledge people
spitting thanks ray william johnson love
and more hey des
you got acknowledged he's spitting facts
[Music]
you can you gotta at least like love him
or hate him he's spitting facts god I
hate that sentence love him or hate him
me so she can return it and remote love
them or hate them whatever your opinion
is you have to think this way you say
say it about anything yeah I like this
joke actually the more I think about it
what's someone that everyone loves ice
cream love it or hate it but you have to
acknowledge it tastes good good good
observational comedy there Felix you
really made the point
so this meme started off with do you
agree with him love him or hate him you
gotta acknowledge he's spitting facts
whatever your opinion is drop it he's
spitting facts what is his name is
Colonel something do you agree with him
whatever your opinion is you have to put
it aside cuz he's spitting thanks
there's Sun over these memes and then it
just of course like any memes it just
becomes a competition or who can make
the most incomprehensible version of
this meme from villages
[Music]
I mean listen whatever your opinion is
just drop it whatever however you
perceive villager 69 just drop it you're
spinning Thanks that was big that's art
yes love or hate PD PI you're gotta
acknowledge he's spitting facts here
this is my third shout out to
jacksepticeye hope you guys enjoy it
guys please you have to understand
whatever your opinion is about Sonic the
Hedgehog while he's in a critical
condition at st. Mary's Hospital and
physically unable to speak straight
facts
you gotta acknowledge that he's spitting
facts is that a freaking sonic knob or
he's the link please tell me it's is
like it's is like right bah bah bah bah
bah bah bah bah bah loving lover hates
Catlins world you gotta acknowledge he's
spitting straight thanks listen whatever
your opinion is of Donald Trump like I
get it all these bad things VBB love
them or hate them you gotta acknowledge
him when you spit face listen whatever
your opinion is about the 21 kid mean
you got acknowledged he's stupid I was
nine times teen
[Music]
mob or hate him Steve is going crazy
I rate
spitting facts me I'll give it an 8 I
actually kind of like it I'm sorry
come on that site I like it okay next
meme fanners made it bounce back you
thought it was over with Marvel Thanos
memes oh no no no no how long is this
gonna last like two or three days reign
fire but sire our troops just do it make
a crossover meme are you sure this will
work
haha I have no idea yeah this is this is
so weak posed to me but SIA we're in the
wrong movie just do it I don't even know
where this sprung kungfu panda open the
fridge but saya you just opened it two
minutes ago and it was empty
yeah this is awful more endgame memes
but sire they will die in new just do it
Venice rain fire curve is Versailles our
true that'ss help me I think the only
way to summarizes meme next meme Peppa
the pig back at it again with another
meme why you my ask why are people
freaking out about Peppa the pig well
she has a seven inch height of seven
point one inches I think that's how you
say it I don't know inches it makes no
sense
which makes pepper the pig a freaking
giant can we talk about how big pepper
the biggest fit for the pig seven inches
I don't know stretch the nega six - how
tall does that make daddy pig oh my
I could literally crawl inside mommy pig
think about it MBA Scouts when they see
Peppa pig's High Dam oh man
why am i laughing it's so unfunny pepper
the pig height 7 inches Clifford the dog
height 25 pathetic Peppa Peppa Pig
height 7 inches LeBron James 6 8 can
anyone beat Peppa the pig well play for
the how big is Clifford the guy
wait how big is Pikachu how tall is
Pikachu 40 centimeters what how tall is
PewDiePie what all right we're gonna
have to fix this instead of Swedish
youtuber I wanted to say 7 2 inches
reality can be whatever I want
brick you Peppa the pig freak you next
babe oh yeah 5 2 rated 7 1 inches
because that's her height that is the
joke next me me when my mom went
shopping for three hours and she says
we're going to another store after this
say psych right now this is another meme
it's very epic time traveller what year
is it me 2019 time traveler so World War
3 hasn't happened yet me say psych right
now ha say psych right now me hey wanna
play minecraft friend what's that I play
for that say psych right now time
traveler who the heck is that thought me
that's Belle Delphine time traveler oh
okay wait you mean president Delphine
save sack right now goddamn Time
Traveller's always trying to troll me
well it started with Belle Delphine's
Instagram getting deleted say sack right
now not-safe-for-work
cosplayer bill Delphine Instagram
account removed for violating nudity
guidelines taught vanquished thought
gone listen I understand that you think
all taught equal bad but I gotta say not
all taught equal bad and even though I'm
not 100% sure about Belle didn't and you
know at least she's not throwing cats
over her head okay
love me or hate Belle Delphine its
spitting facts enter code P PI by the
way I haven't promoted in a while cuz I
thought you guys knew by now but I think
there's a 30% off it's probably finished
already
now the next meme isn't really a meme
but
as I play minecraft now I just enjoy it
it makes me laugh okay
USA soldiers when they hear popcorn in
the microwave this is awful by the way
okay ladies gamers when they hear
someone open a bottle of soda only
Minecraft gamers can truly understand
it's a joke it's a joke alright love me
or hate it's your pin is spinning facts
if you want to be mad about this meme
then creeper oh man me peacefully
building the creeper behind me it's
funny laughs only Minecraft gamers will
truly understand perfectly cut scream
compilation my girlfriend cooks me bacon
finally the final maim everyone area 51
memes still going very strong for
whatever reason okay
for some reason area 51 is the meme
that's gonna carry through this year
when you open a room in area 51 and find
one of the boys who went missing oh this
is so dice the US Air Force has also
begun their a negotiation process
they're trying to bargain with us
but don't listen no matter what tricks
they use no matter what temptation they
try to fill any ain't gonna be worth it
because what they're hiding inside is
way more valuable than any minecraft
Diamonds you could ever possibly imagine
if no one attacks area 51
we will revive Club Penguin oh man they
really know how to speak to my gamer the
hardest choices require the strongest
wills our fantasies will never be
quenched okay don't listen
just for the record straight okay this
is all a joke do not go near area 51
don't go in towards area 51 it's a
military zone don't do it you could get
hurt other people get hurt you could go
to jail it's not worth it
not even for the meme okay just send one
of the drones okay you can have a drone
with flame thrown it's a joke you're
supposed to laugh anyway that's it for
this week's meme review hope you guys
enjoyed smash like subscribe we're
almost at 100 mil merch is always
available though it's not limited
edition that was a Trixie almost didn't
see and as always so way back in the
mine I got to my pickaxe swinging from
side it does not work at all what you
never played super simulator you know
it's fun right I'm not supposed to give
my opinion but give it a try and then
you can tell me if it's good or not not
convinced yet okay I'll cut you a deal
the game is available for free and
that's a great price
[Music]